on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Facebook and uncensored it
was once voted the greatest ever Britain
our new poll reveals today's generation
I think Winston Churchill was just a
racist what's behind this war on Western
history as could explain Albania for
Britain's migrant crisis the country's
Crown Prince joins me live to demand we
show his country some respect
us Americans prepare to vote in crucial
elections which could dramatically
restate U.S politics or talk to one of
Donald Trump's top advisors
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
good evening Fernando welcome to
Facebook when I'm censored cop 27 is
underway build again as our last chance
to save the planet well spoiler alert I
doubt it will just like the last 26 last
chances before it failed to deliver
every year they arrive by private jets
to pontificate on the end of the world
and every year with no sense of irony
they produce a staggering amount of hot
air and deliver very little
the answer is not to renew our addiction
to hydrocarbons and and and uh to give
in the answer is is and that's why I'm
here the answer is to accelerate the
adoption of Green Solutions
really is that really why you're there
Boris or is it because you're addicted
to making everything all about you our
prime minister Rishi suneck is there
that's all that needs to be there from
this country like CO2 in the atmosphere
Boris just doesn't want to go away and
he had plenty of time to make a
difference himself we've had 27 years of
dire warnings at Cobb and 27 years of
the problem only getting worse this is
what's saving the planet looks like well
frankly we better start looking for
another one and if you roll your eyes at
the very mention of this subject it's
almost certainly because of people like
this
why does it take young people like me
on the M25
billion graduate from the Matt Hancock
School of crying without tears
you know it's been such a tough year for
so many people and there's William
Shakespeare putting it simply for
everybody that you know we can get on
with our lives
the problem is that nobody's listening
to young people like that shrieking
Banshee precisely because she's up on a
bleeping Gantry on the M25 and the
thousands of people sitting below for
hours of traffic Mayhem and not to blame
for climate change they're just trying
to get to work far from persuading
anybody I believe these petulant
protesters are hopelessly out of touch
they whine about their future but
they're also whining about our past take
this weekend survey from the policy
exchange Think Tank which soldiers one
in five young people now have a positive
view of some Winston Churchill our great
wartime leader the man who face down
Adolf Hitler and helped lead the world
to Freedom is now derided there's
nothing but a racist
the climate change is a serious as the
protesters what you believe it is and by
the way I think it is a very serious
issue they should recognize we have a
lot more likely to solve it with people
like Winston Churchill in charge well
I'm joined Now by Iman ayton who's
organized her own black lives matter
protest including the likes of actor
John villega and Madonna and Royal
historian and author Sir Anthony Selden
so welcome to both of you this is a
really incendiary debate now never used
to be used to be just everyone used to
agree Winston Churchill was a national
hero who saved us from the Nazis and
that was it but now he's not and I'll
start Iman by saying this I understand
why young people look back at some of
the things that Churchill was recorded
as saying some of the views that he held
and I understand why it may color the
judgment about him literally actually
um but I also believe you should take
all great figures in totality I agree
whether it's Gandhi Mandela Churchill
whoever it may be and the Welter of
positives for Winston Churchill to me
outweigh attitudes and occasional
comments which were by far the norm of
that era
and not I wouldn't be tolerated today
and what's your reaction to that I
totally agree with you so I don't
actually hop on on the covert racism or
the kind of you know the comments like
black people are savages and you know
Indians are obesity race I don't
actually hold on to that because you're
right it was during those times not that
it's acceptable we can safely say it
wasn't what I hold on to for example is
yes he was a hero I think I was given
the same kind of narrative that most
people were that this is a British hero
um admittedly it was only when I saw
Churchill was a racist that graffiti
that was written on his statue during
black lives matter that prompted me as a
random person to say you know I'm going
to go home and research Winston
Churchill and in doing that I found the
two things that resonated with me
personally the first was the four
million Indians that died due to the
Bengal famine which was a direct result
of Winston Churchill's decision making
the second would happen
fair enough I'll come back to you
because that is simply not true okay the
mythology that's built up around what
happened and I'll let the Great
historian fill in the blanks here but
the there's a lot of Mythology that's
been fermenting about Churchill's
culpability over the Bengal family but
for something else he didn't cause the
famine famine was caused by a cyclone it
was then massively exacerbated by a
failure to get resource and food into
the area because of the war and because
of Japan's Stranglehold on the area and
so on and so on Churchill did direct
other countries building America and
Australia to try and send grain to
Bengal but he also prioritized when it
really came to it British troops who
were going to die of hunger as well and
as a British prime minister in a war I'm
not sure you can sincerely blame him no
which I've heard and I totally agree so
my point is it's very easy to say that
Churchill caused the famine and the
death of four million people but
actually when you get into the Weeds
about what happened there that's simply
not accurate historically well I said it
was due to his decision making and
secondly that's not the only thing that
resonated with me the second thing that
resonated with me with his was the fact
that he built Kenyan concentration camps
so please call me and tell me I am wrong
he built Kenyan concentration camp seven
years after World War II seven years
after defeating fascism seven years
after getting rid of concentration camps
produced he decided after seven years of
growth and learning and all of this
peace and all of this amazingness that
Britain has achieved we're now going to
build concentration camps and not for
Jews this time it's going to be for
Kenyans and we're now going to start
making pillars or or sorry uh rather uh
like these kind of different instruments
that literally crush and rip the
testicles off of Kenyan men and we're
going to do that seven years after
defeating okay so yes I've got a
different perspective we've heard the
view and it's a view clearly shared by a
lot of young people I've been staggering
these new statistics now of people who
really dislike Churchill and have no
respect for him
well I think it's partly uh the fact he
was built up to be such a big figure but
for me uh everything uh that has been
identified
um that Iman is talking about is
important and needs to be weighed into
the equation thank you Anthony that's
all I want that's what I want that or
because we are all
mixtures of good and bad every leader
and I think for young people to have the
evidence and weigh it up I'm just going
to mention three good things he did and
by the way I agree the treatment are in
uh of the kikuyu tribe in Kenya during
that period of suppressing Mao Mao was
utterly deployed seven years after World
War II April 1952 onwards uh uh but this
is what he did he did uh on the welfare
state he was a core person building the
welfare state before the first world war
and as prime minister in the second
world war he oversaw the beverage report
and encouraged it uh which has been
enormously the benefit secondly he was
the first politician to spot
um the the end of the Cold War in 1953
he made an extraordinary speech after
the death of Stalin saying we can't
carry on as we were and sadly there was
uh what he did in the second world or
where Hitler six million Jews 50 million
dead in that war he did stand up when
Britain was alone so
um to give young people uh the evidence
on both sides I'll let them come after
they're in judgment and to recognize
that every leader asked me you peers
everyone is a mixture of good and bad
but not most of it not monstrous and
that's my issue not everyone is a
mixture of monstrous and heroes
exciting to actually Crush
all right take my one of my heroes like
Nelson Mandela he was on the no-fly list
for this country throughout most of the
70s right he was a man and many viewed
to be a terrorist and then he came out
and he turned out to be one of the
all-time great peacemakers now again do
you take his life in totality Mandela or
do you say that actually anyone involved
in any form of activity which could be
clouds of terrorism is a monster and
therefore there is no chance for a
public figure to redeem Nelson Mandela
thus sanction making pliers that crushed
and ripped the testicles off of black
men did Nelson Mandela do that fizz what
he did sanction was he sanctioned
activity which by today's standards
would be construed as terrorists but so
we can safely say that yes everyone is
in fact I'm not negating that I think
the issue I think my point my point is
that you can take almost any historical
figure and you can paint a picture as
Anthony said of negative and positive to
me what Churchill achieved in World War
II
overrides everything else but why though
so why does that supersede the fact that
he uh caused thousands tens of thousands
of black deaths and potentially again
it's it's arguable but potentially his
decision-making led to the deaths of
millions of Indians so what you're
saying but that's not the deaths but
okay so but what we can say
categorically is what I said about the
Kenyan concentration camp so if you
think that the Kenyan concentration
camps wasn't monstrous and what you're
doing is you're negating the thoughts
and feelings and experiences well I
don't actually get anything that
Churchill did on the negative side I
think a lot of the things he said were
certainly racially tinged things that he
did what about the players I've just
told you no no we're not defending that
at all right so that's the point we need
to balance the argument I agree with
that yeah but my point is
I agree but where On Your Balanced
argument does the pendulum swing to
saving the world from the north I agree
no so this is the thing I'm not the
extremist I don't throw the baby out
with the bath water maybe you're used to
those types of guests here I'm not that
type of person I Believe In Balance so I
actually agree with you think he did
incredible things but I think it's also
important to acknowledge that he also
did really monstrous things and we
should present both arguments and allow
people to establish okay so the sheer
fact that we're having this discussion
now that that we are here able to talk
is because he led this country to stand
up against a fascist dictator who like
many of the leaders in the world today
many want to China Russia North Korea
and more want to squeeze free debate the
kind of discussion we have at the moment
we can go back have our separate lives
we're not going to be put in we wouldn't
be having it under Nazi Germans so
absolutely I'm not disputing so give
them the facts and I think that perhaps
it was inevitable there was so much
adulation of Churchill there's now a
steep and that's a that's a really
extraordinary figure eighty percent of
young people have a negative picture I
think that maybe in five years time it
will rebalance I I think myself will
disagree Imam on this that I think that
that it will be overwhelmingly positive
about Churchill while not ignoring the
downside and I think if people can learn
about Humanity then that that people's
flaws uh including you know what he did
or what he sanctioned as prime minister
uh in the 1950s in Kenya weigh all that
then that's real education that's what
history is about I mean there are proper
arguments to be had about the the carpet
bombing of Dresden in World War II which
many people think was completely
unacceptable Churchill would argue if he
was here he's not but if he was he would
argue it was a necessary evil to
facilitate the Hasting of the ending of
the war now a lot of people don't agree
with that historically but if you're a
wartime leader you've got to make
horrendous decisions decisions I totally
agree with you and I bring it back to
just having an inclusive mindset and I
think that's the issue here that many
people seem to not uh or let me just put
it this way I don't think people are
disputing the fact that he's here I
think that many people are disputing the
fact that he is also a monster and that
is where the problem lies appears I'm
not saying he's not a hero everything
that you've just said everything that
you just said I agree I think it's
awesome but I also have to take into
account that the Indian population that
died potentially because of his decision
making probably wouldn't have called him
a hero I have to take into account that
the men that were having their testicles
ripped from their bodies probably
wouldn't call Winston Churchill a hero
either so again it comes down to an
inclusive mentality when you take into
account everyone's feelings it becomes a
lot harder to then definitively say
someone as a hero or a villain what you
usually do is say they are both you take
into account they are racist you take
into account that they're a hero and you
take into account that they and so we
found Churchill uh that well I do I
think he sanctions some monstrous things
personally I didn't think he was a
monster I think he had a deeply so
sanctioning much compassionless things
doesn't make you a monster is that right
Anthony let's just make sure you're
clear do monstrous things you're not a
monster is that correct I think that is
that correct let me ask let me ask you a
difficult question do you think do you
think the unleashing of two nuclear
weapons in World War II uh Hiroshima and
Nagasaki was that justified was that
monstrous
I think those types of things are
monstrous I don't think that kills
anyone answers okay so you're calling
that you're calling the American
president that did that a monster
another one that kills anyone else
brought to an end a war that would have
killed many many many more people but it
still doesn't negate the fact that it
was monstrous to the people that died
and that's what I'm trying to say before
now what about your feelings and white
people's feelings and Jewish about white
people feelings above everyone else that
had a negative
should that I think you let yourself
down white people British people Jewish
people the people that I typically this
is where I'm coming from the people that
I typically find defend Winston
Churchill there have been many blacks
let's be honest with ourselves here but
I typically find it's majority white
because we have this this real kind of
um admiration for the man and so a lot
of people quite randomly because you
saved us from Germany they're taking
consideration I don't think anybody
thinks the Winston nobody thinks he was
an angel at all but he took a lot of
very difficult decisions people are
negating the fact that he is in monster
that is the issue be balanced all right
your major point you made your point uh
Anthony yeah talk to you quickly about
your book The Path of Peace walking the
Western Front way couldn't be more
timely obviously remembrance Sunday this
weekend when you wrote This Book
have we learned the lessons that led to
the catastrophe of the first world war
do you think so no categorically not I
mean as I was walking that the third
world war was uh in Ukraine perhaps
about to unfold it was the vision of a
young Soldier peers who uniquely it
would seem had a vision on building a
path to peace which I think is
fundamental where we can have people his
vision was of all Nations or all face or
backgrounds walking side by side
together to try to learn from the dead
from both sides so I walked back last
summer a thousand kilometers a million
Paces through soil where 10 million 10
million had bled to death or had their
lives totally wrecked uh in the effort
of trying to build a path to BC was an
extraordinary uh Visionary
um uh young young man and so no but it
is by building understanding Building
Bridges with each other and think maybe
not rushing myself to condemn other
people to understand why they did things
that we have the best Hope For Humanity
and that's exactly why I wrote the book
on the Western Front way now is the
world's biggest commemoration project
everyone can walk it or cycle it
um it's going to become like the
northern Camino I think it was the best
idea to come out of the first world war
peers even though it categorically
hasn't ended the second world well
didn't stop the Second World War uh and
when what other hope is there unless we
just walk together respect our
difference and indeed love each other
for our difference which is an inclusive
mentality by the way well I think we've
respected each other's differences thank
you someone goes for us that we love
each other yeah
it's Anthony Selden great to see you
Imani thank you very much for coming in
I appreciate it well coming up it's 12
000 albanians arriving on small boats an
invasion the Home Secretary thinks so
the Crown Prince of Albania things
defending simply not that he's called it
an improvement to British Society well
that debate next
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
well welcome back go number 10 said
tonight that a new deal preventing
migrants leaving France to reach Britain
is now in its final stages earlier Rishi
sunak held talks to president macro on
the sidelines of cop27 but much of a
debate about the crisis has been
overshadowed by criticism of Home
Secretary Suella bravaman's use of
language
the British people deserve to know which
party is serious about stopping the
invasion and
[Music]
is not this laborer in charge they would
be allowing all the Albanian criminals
to come to this country they would be
allowing all the small boats to come to
the UK
well the Crown Prince of Albania
responded on Twitter calling this
disproportionate slander and purely
xenophobic so criminal gangs abusing
wide open British Borders or a
convenient scapegoat for a government
that's lost control well joining me now
is talk TV presenter Richard tires and
the Crown Prince of Albania Prince like
it well thank you both indeed for
joining me uh if I could talk to you
first uh princess Leica thank you very
much for joining the program tonight I
read your Tweet with great interest they
were clearly incent by the use of
language by the Home Secretary I share
your anger at the language she used I
thought it was completely unnecessary
however and it isn't important however I
think I think the British people have
been surprised to discover now that the
majority of people coming into the
country illegally on these boats across
the channel are now from Albania which
is not a war-torn country at the moment
and they're just bemused as to why this
is happening so let me start with Zoella
bravaman's views why were you so angered
by those
thank you very much PS for welcoming me
on your show it's I'm in Tirana and it's
a wonderful opportunity to actually
Express the human aspect of this issue
today this afternoon I had a cordial
conversation with the British Ambassador
and he reconfirmed to myself as well as
as he has reconfirmed to the Albanian
authorities that the comments are not a
reflection of the British government and
it's not the political stance of the
British government towards Albania and I
would be very happy to say that Albania
and and the United Kingdom have
fantastic relations we are working on a
number of multilateral stances we've
we're allies in the war in Ukraine uh
Albania is a cosigner in the security
Council in protecting the rise and
freedoms of ukrainians albanians are
actively working within the conference
of NATO and making sure that we are a
proud contributor we've welcomed over 4
000 refugees from Afghanistan to Albania
we are continuously trying to work on
different fronts so we're currently
under attack from Iranian cyber warfare
which has had huge impacts on our
cybernetic infrastructure and we are on
the Forefront of This Global
stance of freedom
but obviously The Stance and the
rhetoric which has been used in the
General Media has had an impact and I
have taken this unorthodox stance in I
come it's going away from the Royal
position of silence and I thought that
it was neither that we have to mention
that's the majority of albanians in the
UK are
hard-working individuals we have and the
12 000 albanians inconsidering the
proportionality of the situation we have
the United Kingdom has over 6.5 million
immigrants 12 000 albanians cannot be
considered a Invasion and I'm very sad
that's this harsh tone of events is
having impacts on the hard-working
albanians currently living in England
I've spoken to family friends who are
unique and some of them have actually
pulled their children out of schools
because they feel that this xenophobic
attitude is reflecting on their lives
and this is why I took this unorthodox
stance and actually making a few
comments at very late at night on
Twitter because I believe very strongly
that we have to find tangible results of
overcoming this issue and building upon
the very strong relations that we
albanians and the UK have together have
you had any conversation with the new
prime minister Richie sunak about this
I I have not and I I know that's the
Albanian prime minister is in contact in
this Community Aid and he has also come
out with a very very strong stance that
this is not a reflection of the
Fantastic relations that we have as two
different countries
relations can't be uh approved let me
bring in Richard ties here Richard
there's a lot of agitation in the UK
about these new statistics which seem to
be suggesting that there is a a large
number of young Albanian men coming in
illegally and the suspicion is that many
of them are coming to join gangs in the
UK now it's hard to assess I guess
exactly what percentage may be and it
quite clear that many of them will be
legitimate and genuine Asylum Seekers
and refugees where do we draw the line
here what is your view of this
well it appears I'm the person that
broke the story a few months ago that
four in ten of the migrants are coming
from Albania a NATO member and as the
Crown Prince quite rightly says we have
good relations and the vast vast
majority of urbanions are wonderful
people and we go to uh on holiday there
and vice versa but let's remember peers
these people are coming here in these
boats illegally they are illegally
entering the country about 12 000 of
them now when actually albanians can
happily legally lawfully come on a
six-month Visa they can come and work in
the United Kingdom it costs them a few
hundred pounds to get such a Visa so if
they are legitimate decent good
law-abiding citizens of Albania that
want to come and contribute to British
Society why they're not coming legally
and lawfully the only reason that they
would pay 10 times that amount to come
on a perilous journey and a small boat
across the channel regrettably is
because they may have different
objectives we know that it's a question
of fact that Albanian criminals are the
largest group of foreign Nationals in
our jails and we know that many of these
albanians are disappearing within days
and going to join the Albanian criminal
gangs that have now completely taken
over and brutally violently dominated
our cocaine trade our cannabis trade in
a horrific way in the towns and cities
across the country they're making vast
vast profits they need more foot
soldiers to get rid of the huge profits
their money laundering through car
washes they're setting up barber shops
in towns and high streets across the
country even candy shops now and you
know the British people have had enough
and the Home Secretary expressed the
frustration of millions and millions of
British people that this criminal
activity has to stop it's no reflection
of the wonderful albanians that the
Crown Prince mentioned it is a
reflection of the deep concern about the
significant brutally violent Albanian
criminal gangsters that are causing
chaos okay violence and murder on the
streets okay let me put this back to the
Crown Prince I mean there's some
interesting statistics here where in
2020 50 albanians arrived on these small
boats in 2021 800 and in 2022 12 000 so
there is clearly a massive seismic shift
in numbers here and it is true as
Richard Tice says that there are
currently 1 336 albanians imprisoned in
England and Wales and that is the
highest foreign nationality incarcerated
in that year so there is clearly a
problem with a Criminal element here and
the number that are now making the
crossing is exponentially rising at such
a rate that it would seem to suggest
that this can't be divorced in many of
these cases from potential criminality
what would you say to that
well the first thing I'm a advocate of
free movement and it's not true that
albanians are given the opportunity to
travel freely in the United Kingdom
they're not issued visas and when you
are forced uh you're not given that
opportunity a free movement a lot of
youngsters from not only Albania but the
majority of our beans are coming up from
other European countries because of a
pandemic and because of the foreseen
recession which Europe is going to be
facing in the next two years so a lot of
these young albanians are trying to find
means and methods of Crossing into
Europe
and unfortunately once they take that
route which is the legal route they are
the victims of gangs organized crime and
this is something which I I'm I've
spoken to you I messed about I'm trying
to promote in the sense that we have to
find tangible ways of making sure that
our brains are able to travel uh
securely to the UK and the majority 53
percent of albanians who do go to UK are
got legitimate concerns they have
different issues and they are given a
permission to stay
those Elements which are forced to go
through the illegal roots
often don't have the opportunity and
that's a freedom to go back to Albania
and we all know that the new modern
Tick-Tock uh Instagram view of
immigration in UK is a blurred image of
reality and I believe if it's working
with the Albanian government working
with the corporations with on the
international level we're able to
provide this free movement majority of
albanians who go with this false
impression of a glorious life in UK will
return I do take hindrance that the
majority of albanians are going to go
into crime a lot of albanians
wants to be a proactive They See England
as a fantastic country which has
provided over the generations servitude
my own family in 1939 when Albania was
invaded by the fascists we went to the
UK we were given uh refuge and it's
something which I I resonates very very
much myself I myself was educated uh in
the UK and I was given the opportunity
to join the Royal Military Academy
centers where I commissioned as a
officer and I see that uh we have a very
strong friendship but I I don't like
this improportionate and we talk about
proportionality
of the British narrative focusing on
albanians when at the same time we're
talking about the month of June where we
had 100 more albanians than other
countries and legitimately
other countries from the Middle East as
well as Africa have different issues
of this debate when you said you spoke
to the the British Ambassador the
British Ambassador directly apologized
to you for the use of language by the
Home Secretary the use of the phrase
invasion
so we we don't uh nor has Albania
requested
apology because we understand that there
is a very uh strong internal debate
within the UK the situation is very
intense and it's our uh
stance not to be involved in local
politics of the United Kingdom I think
Albania has its own intense politics and
I've heard very strong words from the
albani opposition understand to leave
that a lot of albanians traveling to the
UK are albanians who are from the right
of the political Specter that don't find
Opportunities within the country but in
the center of the origins of Albania
Albania was a country which for over 50
years was a victim of the harshest
regime of communism
we've come out of Communism finding
ourselves in a prolonged transition
period which has had an enormous effect
on the lives of the people and many
albanians who are getting a wage of less
than 250 pounds a month wanted to see a
change and the overall Albania is a
developing country and a country which
is having incredible tourism over the
last years encouraging uh in foreign
investment a lot of these benefits are
not being seen by the majority of young
albanians in The Villages so there are
issues which I hope that we will be able
to tackle but we have to tackle this
okay together let me just give up this
is a need I understand let me give a
final word there to Richard is anything
the Crown Prince said made you think
again about your position on this
not at all peers I would remind the
Crown Prince we don't have a free
movement arrangement with Albania we do
have a Visa scheme I checked it today
it's 259 pounds you'll get a decision
within three or four weeks no one is
forced to come illegally to the United
Kingdom in small boats uh and many of
them disappearing as I say within days
to join gangs just recently a number of
them were caught in cannabis Farms we
know that some Albanian criminals who've
just been deported within days have come
back across the channel in boats I think
the Crown Prince needs to reflect on the
fact that unfortunately there is a
significant criminal element who are
coming to the United Kingdom and who are
brutally violently uh targeting our
towns and cities making illegal profits
and it's got to stop we've we've heard
both sides of your argument very loudly
and clearly Richard Tice thank you very
much and Crown Prince like I do really
appreciate you coming on the program
thank you very much
no thank you very much sir it's a
pleasure thank you we'll still come
tonight Gavin Williamson is back in the
cabinet and already back to embarrassing
the government this time over foul mouth
text to a female colleague and as I
speak tonight is a new report in the
guardian saying that a senior civil
servant claims Williamson told them to
Slit your throat Charming is it time to
get rid of this hapless goon one more
time
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to Facebook organizing
Gavin Williamson back in government the
words you feared you'd never hear again
it was sacked of course as defense
secretary for leaking sensitive military
information to a journalist he was
sacked again as education secretary of
the chaos over exams during covid and
then of course he was rewarded with a
Knighthood because that's the way our
system works here here he is failing to
apologize to me for his government's
unlawful conduct over Kobe contracts
I'm sorry you acted unlawfully yes or no
well the government would never aim to
act uh unlawfully and obviously
guilty of it so are you sorry and and of
course yeah you guys find it so hard if
we're not in the situation where the
decisions we've taken have been uh
upheld by a judge that's certainly
something we'd never aim to do so you're
sorry
yeah uh deeply regret it yes thank you
thank you
eventually it's like blood out of a
stone wasn't it anyway uh breaking news
tonight uh well that's all if you don't
know the background to this it's been
branded unacceptable by the Prime
Minister Rishi sunak who to my my
bafflingly brought him back to the
government despite being warned that
he'd been bullying people again this was
over trying to bully his way into the
Queen's funeral
and then he of course was rude and
obnoxious to the achievement at the time
uh is it time he gets fired for a third
time and I'm joined by my my Stella pack
tonight talk to me Jessica uh political
journalist Avis and Tina and Daily
Mirror Associated so Kevin McGuire and
in a moment we're going to talk also
about the crucial midterm elections in
America where Donald Trump's former
senior adviser Jason Miller's a lot to
get through tonight
um let me start with the patio about
Gavin Williamson a story breaking the
moment I heard that he'd been sending
vile texts hey it was the least
surprising news of the Millennium and B
I thought there are going to be a
million other texts right this guy the
only reason he could possibly get so
many jobs is he's so vile to everybody
and he knows all their secrets because
he was the chief Whip and so they keep
promoting him to keep him keep his mouth
shut the guardian tonight a senior civil
servant claims Gavin Williamson told him
to Slit your throat and what they felt
was a sustain campaign of bullying was
defense secretary the mod official told
the guardian William cement the
extraordinary months for them other
civil sermons in a meeting on a separate
occasion told them to jump out of a
window
I mean this is unbelievable it is and
sunax damaged himself by bringing him
back yeah I stood on the steps of down
industry and said I'm going to rule with
Integrity where is the Integrity of
bringing back sagav who is a known bully
and what Williamson will really worry
about is there will be more texts and
messages and emails because you can
dispute
because it's his currency
why else would he be there yeah Esther
why else would he be there but the
problem is if that's the case no one
will be in our politics because that's
the culture of Westminster these people
rise
it's not a normal thing to say but I
just think people have you said this but
you're gonna slip their throats you
don't answer that how many access I'm
joking
remember you actually you make a point I
mean I know I know from my time running
a newspaper you know you speak to
Alistair gamble long enough when he was
running Communications with Tony Blair
he'd be effing and blinding and
threatening everybody uh I think this
this has been historically the kind of
language they all think they need to use
but we're in different times now but I
think that's what's great that's the
problem we're trying to transition into
a politics that's more respectable
that's more cordial but it hasn't
happened yet you know I always draw up
sort of um parallels to David Cameron
for instance because I said pretty
patelli she was in David Cameron's
government she would have been fired
actually you wouldn't have been let to
get on with this kind of bullying of
civil servants and I said that Boris is
because he has no standards in this
cabinet he's going to keep her on and I
think Rishi has to try his best to move
away from that but obviously you can't
if you bring this person back into
government so it's really it's really
difficult exactly you kind of have to
bring people with the relevant
experience but that doesn't have this
baggage and that's all of them all of
them have this hey Russell or uh secure
stamina the football I don't know he
knows this but Arsenal beat Chelsea away
we're both gooners so we were we're
actually celebrating and actually I was
also discovered with Kendrick Lamar
other rap star because I that's the kind
of crowd that I hang with at a week
actually it used to be a Tottenham fan
is that an Arsenal fan whoa that's weird
yeah which was a great great place yeah
but uh it's interesting talking to
Kirsten because he was very light and I
was thinking you have to be reveling in
all this he went my whole Mantra to the
shadow cabinet is no complacency that
the enemy now is complacency do your
jobs do them well don't get complacent
which I thought was very actually good
advice but it must be difficult not to
be a little bit like is there any end to
this with the Tories I mean one thing
after another they bring back Zoella
bravaman she's straight back into more
Scandal they bring back Gavin Williamson
he's going to probably have to go now
for telling people to Slit their throats
I mean it is the Tories are basically
handing the next government to me to
labor on a plate they are in a sense but
I mean I don't think labor can get too
excited yet because they haven't
actually trialed any policy so the only
reason that they are ahead in the polls
is because the the Tory government is in
such shambles going back to what you
said actually about pretty Patel and
David Cameron I think that has a lot to
do with fragility and I think that the
reason that Rishi sunak has to keep
people like Gavin Williamson and swella
braveman in his cabinet is because if
they're on the back benches they're much
more of a danger to him than if they're
in his cabinet you know causing and the
talent is sort of there because the
thing is if you had someone with kind of
the sort of more right-wing Acumen of
Suella Brahman but not with the same
baggage not with the lack of attacked I
think she's a completely tackleless
politician she would be threatened
because she knows that none of her
behavior will be acceptable and that's
what she's doing it because not not all
Tory MPS but here of like Gavin
Williamson my prediction my prediction
is he'll be gone it'll be gone by the
end of the week well so because there's
going to be a thousand more text
messages you don't just come out with
these things once or twice it still is
modus operands
so next line which we heard from uh
grunt shops the transportation is it
happened before he was brought back
doesn't matter no but because it's just
too embarrassing we were actually
bringing things back uh tonight the New
York Post Justin former president Donald
Trump has told allies he could have now
it's a 2024 presidential run tonight at
a rally for a higher Republican Senate
candidate JD Vance the post has learned
let's bring in Jason Miller a former
senior advisor to president Trump
um Jason welcome to the program great to
have you on uh huge anticipation that
Donald Trump may even announce as early
as tonight he's going to run again my
guess is he will run again pretty much
whatever happens in the midterms short
of every candidate he's promoted losing
which I think is unlikely let me ask you
a question though you worked closely
with the man is it a good thing for
America if Donald Trump runs again with
a you know a 50 50 chance perhaps of
winning the White House again
well I'm obviously a trump partisan I
work from both 2016 and 2020 and so I
very much want to see Trump come back in
2024. I think what we've seen in the U.S
with the economy going downhill with the
inflation all the things that everybody
realizes and why that we're going to
have this tidal wave of an election
tomorrow that's all part of the reason
why I want to see President Trump come
back but I think more importantly peers
on the global stage when you have a weak
American democracy a weak leadership in
the White House it reverberates all the
way across the world and you see the
rise of Russia the rise of China and all
the bad guys don't have anyone to push
back on them that's a very interesting
moment this week I thought when the the
rising Republican star is the Florida
governor Ron DeSantis expected to to get
easily reelected in the midterms and
Trump suddenly we've been you know sort
of not saying anything publicly but
knifing him privately suddenly he did it
publicly let's take a look
let's say there it is Trump at 71 Rhonda
sanctimonious at 10 percent
now I'm going to hand it to Trump he is
a master of giving people very damaging
uh mocking nicknames but it also opened
up this very real possibility now that
he does get challenged by DeSantis who
is pretty near half his age uh done a
very good job in Florida he's very
popular there and he's seen as the sort
of Trump without all the baggage of
matters what do you make of the santis
and was it helpful for Trump to do this
right before an important election for
the Republicans
yeah great question so in a conventional
lens if you look through this it would
make no sense to go after Ron DeSantis
now right before an election DeSantis is
going to win in a landslide in Florida
to help carry a number of the
Republicans across the finish line but
very clearly president Trump does not
look at things through a traditional
political lens if he had he probably
wouldn't have won in 2016 or come as
close as he would have had in 2020. I
think president Trump clearly is
thinking about DeSantis knows that
DeSantis is likely to challenge him even
in a Republican primary if Trump says
that he's running and so he decided that
admin to Tuesday he's going to throw a
little love tap as they'd say here in
New York at Governor DeSantis so caught
a lot of people off guard they're upset
by it but clearly president Trump's
looking ahead to 2024. President Biden I
mean I would imagine if you're the
Republicans there was you're praying for
uh on running again because Biden looks
half Gaga and he's approaching 80 years
old
yeah and there's a there's a
counter-intuitive Point here in that
Trump announcing early could also Force
Joe Biden to announce early keep in mind
Biden's only real value proposition is
that he defeated president Trump in
2020. a lot of Democrats do not want Joe
Biden running in 2024 they want him to
step aside let in someone else like a
Gavin Newsom or Gretchen Whitmer or one
of the other Governors around the
country so if Trump announces early then
you get Biden early it might lock him in
that could actually be a Big Boon for
president Trump uh whereas if president
Trump were to delay maybe the Democrat
leadership can get to him and convince
Biden you know what it's are we looking
are we looking just quick answer very
are we looking for a slam dunk Red Wave
where they'd say the house and the
Senate
yeah big huge Red Wave you've seen about
a 30 35 Point shift with Independence
just over the last month the bottom has
completely fallen out for Democrats even
CNN is saying that races such as the
Senate contest in New Hampshire are up
for grabs I think Republicans come out
of this with 53 maybe 54 Senate seats
big majority in the house this is going
to be not just
lend any attempt any any chance of Biden
doing anything more substantial while
he's president and we'll open up that
although that's a good thing yeah
it's just more his demeanor which is so
embarrassing I think for America Jason
before letting you go you're involved
with this website uh getter Elon Musk
has taken over Twitter obviously so
technically your rival what do you make
of of Elon Musk very quickly if you
don't mind
yeah obviously Elon Musk is a rival now
that he's the head of Twitter uh but you
have to support what he's trying to do
try to bring some normalcy uh to Twitter
an organization that's gone very far uh
To the Left End a lot of political
discrimination of course the election
2020 and the hunter Biden laptop I have
to support him there Pierce I don't
think the culture at Twitter can be
changed that's the only reason why
that's going to be better than others
Jackson go leave me that uh thank you
very much I agree with you it's going to
be very difficult if anyone can do it
it'll be a genius like musk uh Jason
thank you very much
thank you well next tonight uh we're
going to actually let's go to the break
we'll come back and talk to the back
about this because Trump's return may be
the dominant story for the next few
months
and a bit of eye Mr lead with old Han
cough
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we're actually going to censor that
because that's Madonna's new album from
her bedroom
so embarrassing why doesn't she just
give it up honestly appalling a quick
rash of the pack to Donald Trump Kevin
yeah we'll know how effective he is or
not when you see the midterms the
candidates here but if I was a Democrat
and I agree they don't want Biden but
I'd want Trump I wouldn't want to uh
would you agree with that why on Earth
would you want that we're looking at an
all-out war on uh Reproductive Rights
that could transcended
Trump could win because even though he's
not the ideal he still has he still does
have a lot of uh sort of cachet with
with the Republicans
Democrats the Democrats worst nightmare
would be DeSantis because he is strong
without all the baggies he is but he
also hasn't quite got the Charisma of
trump and Charisma goes a long way in
American votes as we know but if there's
an alienate in the same way and really
look we heard Trump was a joke on the
world stage Putin would have loved him
in place but you see the thing is the
Republicans as well they have all the
talent they have a lot of they have
Nikki Haley they have um the lady from
Arizona they have you know exactly they
don't have any shortage of talent who do
the Democrats have Pete did I mention
about 320 million people we end up with
Trump Biden too the rematch
180 and one but here's the other point
where Trump is now democracy itself is
on the ballot paper when he will not
accept well because so many of them are
election deniers like I agree yeah they
actually stolen yeah let's talk about
talking about people with no Charisma
Hancock with images on the Cog you're
going and we think on Wednesday into the
jungle
that was fantastic television isn't it
I'm so excited
racing no I actually agree with you I
was asking I was waiting hoping he would
appear just so I can vote for him to do
Despicable things I can you know
effectively hurl stuff through the
screen at him
but there is a serious Point Kevin which
is it's constituents I mean where is
this guy yeah they're going to kick him
out in Suffolk and they have to and
again sunax Authority is challenged he's
taken away suspended the whip but he's
got to say this bloke will never be a
Tory MP you've never been politics again
who do you think is going to win I'm a
celebrity well do you know what the
thing is I think he thinks he's about 10
seconds give me a name
um you are you're gonna win it I did say
he's the only reason I would go in would
be to take him off Jill Scott before
England aggressive I don't watch it I
think my intend Little Boy George myself
yeah I think that the Hancock will be
made to eat kangaroo nuts but Thursday
night thank you to my back that's it for
me Keep It Uncensored good night
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign